legal experts are once again talking
about the possibility of the failed
former president Donald Trump being
charged federally under the Espionage
Act because of an audio recording that
has now been obtained that is insanely
damaging to Trump let me give you the
lowdown CNN Trump captured on tape
talking about classified document he
kept after leaving the White House the
details here are critical Federal
prosecutors have an audio recording from
a meeting in summer of 2021 remember
this is after Trump left the White House
in which former president Trump
acknowledges he held on to a classified
Pentagon document about a potential
attack on Iran multiple sources told CNN
undercutting his argument that he
Declassified everything remember Trump
said I Declassified everything I took
but in this audio recording Trump
actually says this is classified I can't
show it to you therefore he did not
declassify it the recording indicates
try understood that he retained
classified material after leaving the
White House on the recording Trump's
comments suggests he would like to share
the information but he's aware of
limitations on his ability
post-presidency to declassify records
two of the sources said if Trump knows I
have something here that has not been
Declassified that is because he didn't
declassify it directly counter to his
claim that he Declassified everything
special counsel Jack Smith who's leading
the Justice Department investigation has
focused on the meeting as part of the
criminal investigation into Trump's
handling of National Security Secrets
sources described the recording as an
important piece of evidence in a
possible case against Trump trump
um prosecutors have asked Witnesses
about the recording and the document
before a Federal grand jury the episode
has generated enough interest for
investigators to question General Mark
milley about the incident the July 2021
meeting was held at Trump's Golf Club in
Bedminster with two people working on
the autobiography of Trump's former
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows as well as
aides employed by Trump including
communication specialist Margot Martin
the attendees did not have security
clearances that would allow them access
to classified information Meadows wasn't
at the meeting
Meadows autobiography includes an
account of what happened at the meeting
during which Trump recalls a four-page
report type typed up by Mark milley
himself containing the General's plan to
attack Iran deploying massive numbers of
troops something he urged Trump to do
more than once during his presidency the
document Trump references was not
produced by Millie this is absolutely
stunning in a number of different ways
there's another article from Business
Insider reports of bombshell Trump
recording suggests prosecutors may have
grounds to charge Trump under the
Espionage Act there are a number of
important issues here
number one if the audio recording is as
described Trump is admitting that he has
unauthorized possession of a document
relating to National Defense Trump's
original claim was I Declassified
everything on the way out either de
facto or through some kind of telepathy
or right it didn't make sense but
Trump's claim was I Declassified all of
it but then Trump is saying in this
meeting when Joe Biden is already
president Trump's out of the White House
he's saying I have something here that
is uh classified so I can't show it to
you this shows Trump knew it was a lie
to say I Declassified everything
secondly the meeting took place in
Bedminster this was not the location of
the search warrant that was served you
will remember the search warrant was
served at Mar-A-Lago
and we said at the time if there are
documents at Mar-A-Lago that Trump isn't
supposed to have there are almost
certainly documents at Bedminster
Michael Cohen Trump's former lawyer said
there are almost certainly documents at
Bedminster and now we have a a recording
that took place at Bedminster where
Trump is there and he has a document
that he says is classified a document he
doesn't actually have the right to just
take with him so we now are expanding
the circle of criminality involving
multiple Trump homes or golf clubs or
whatever you want to call them and then
in addition there are people on the
recording who don't actually have the
security clearance anyway and would
probably be pretty desperate and pretty
incentivized to keep themselves out of
jail
uh and so they could actually become
Witnesses against Donald Trump here this
is an immense story and we are now going
to listen to an interview with one of
Trump's lawyers who's increasingly a TV
lawyer where he seems to be really
struggling to explain this I often have
a much longer list of non-fiction books
that I'd like to read than I actually
have the time for and that's when
summaries of books can be really useful
our sponsor short form is the platform
that goes Way Beyond what other book
summary platforms do because short form
provides a clear and concise overview of
the book that you can read or listen to
in one sitting but you also get a ton of
other crucial context about how the book
fits into the broader topic like for
example I went through the short form
guide for an American sickness it's a
book by Elizabeth Rosenthal about the
financial incentives that plague the U.S
health care System many of which we've
talked about short form perfectly sums
up the book's key points but then it
goes further it looks at the background
on how rosenthal's perspective fits into
the larger debate on American Health
Care and this just gives you a more
complete and balanced understanding of
the book and that's what I love about
short form short form has every
non-fiction genre imaginable and they
publish new book guides every single
week my audience can try short form
totally free and get 25 off a
subscription if you'd like at
shortform.com Pacman the link is down
below